all right mmm
that's the noise sometime I make that
one boy when I wake up okay I do that
one sometimes when I hear some [ __ ]
I do this noise I'll do that with
sometimes you know we got the good we
got the bad and we got the ugly let's
start off with uh with some good man
let's check in with Bishop gun they just
opened up for the Rolling Stones yo yo
what's up Bernal out there in Dallas
how'd that Rolling Stones show go boy
Amen bro how was it the moment we took
the stage they have scanned in 41,000
people already Jesus man
no no it's like the border camo
mm boy come on now were you more nervous
than a regular show walking out on that
type of stage do to be honest I think
that was probably like the easiest show
day I've ever had in my life it was
something it was like exactly opposite
of what I imagined yeah I don't know if
it was just what it was but I just had
this like super calm demeanor all day
just relaxed walked out on stage and
just knew we were gonna kill it it was
like no doubt in my mind is where I was
like last night Dallas you know just a
club level
I was nervous all dear sound check I
guess everything was perfect you know
what I mean like I don't know why or how
that happened that way but it uh it was
something else man Wow
and when the stones when they--when was
like your first experience with them
like when you first saw them like what
was your first interaction with them
like well well first of all when they
pulled up like it wasn't just a ban it
to a soundcheck it was you know we're in
the like the loading dock right behind
the stage catwalk it goes up to the
stage and we're standing back there just
finishing a building drums getting our
production ready with the hands and
stuff you know and all of a sudden all
these guys come out start yelling get
out of the way get the [ __ ] out all the
[ __ ] and so then and then all of a
sudden a bunch of police motorcycles
pull in you know lights all just skirt
in there real quick what do you think
y'all had done a crime or something I I
figured it was just you already know
they laid the snow is May they gonna be
rolling hard
there was six six black so their hands
pulled in behind the police cars and
just like came to a halt and the drivers
all got out like just at the same time
open the doors and there they were they
just walked directly on the stage did a
quick sound check and right back out to
the cars and hauled ass out of there and
what kind of cars were there like ubers
or something or was it like a fancy car
and you know it's not that over elite oh
wow
I'll notice the Mercedes first and they
all got out of different cars each one
of the stones
yeah just one per car and did they look
at you or could they did they could you
see them did they look I mean yeah they
were ten feet from us when I got out but
I just seemed like they were there to do
their [ __ ] you know they just walked
right on stage and I owned it and I mean
I'll tell you what do they are
surprising like even just watching their
show man they still get it dog knows I
mean an amazing rock and roll show just
for doing it for so long I mean there's
the passion still there which is I guess
what we all hope to achieve you know the
kids we we kick or whatever yeah bet it
was very bet so that I can imagine is
very inspiring is just to see that and
be like wow oh I know exactly you know
then after our set we got to uh it was
pretty neat they let us back to their
green room and we got to kind of talk to
them all for a while
you know take some pictures and just
kind of hang out you know it's really
cool man I walked up on my drums before
the show this is earlier in the day then
Charlie Watts the drummer standing there
like tapping my drum heads I'm just
talking about how he loved my kid cuz
it's an old vintage you know Rodgers kit
from the sixties and he recognized that
and uh that was the first experience
have atheneum in person and it was just
like holy [ __ ] yeah one of the most
legendary rock and roll drummers just
like I don't know came up to Mike it was
graced it with his presence even oh yeah
dude that's like that's like if I walked
up and you know George Carlin was uh you
know touching my girlfriend's tits or
something you know I'd be just great oh
my Gracie's titties or if I walked up
and he was just doing my laundry or so I
mean yeah that's crazy and did you know
it was him when you walked up oh yeah oh
yeah there there I mean in just in
Grange I mean their household names and
exactly how we do what's funny is your
dad told me about the stuff yeah I look
I mean obviously was sheltered from
music my mother used to make us listen
to Bryan Adams with him when we would
clean the house dude everything I do I
do it
oh you remember that was a head boy
never the hit and uh and then I remember
your dad's like the Rolling Stones and
I'm like I've never heard of them so I
know man I'm just so proud of you man
congratulations but I'm so happy for you
just and I know everybody at this past
weekend man I know everybody just loves
you know Bishop gun and you know what
all those guys and everybody this past
weekend today earth and every show you
know I'll be will be walking on stage
will to see a whole plethora Gang Gang
yeah
we definitely appreciate that love man
it's uh
helped us know brother oh man well it's
funny man it's funny how the love always
wins you know it's like you know I mean
it's from top to bottom your dad
introduced me to the stones your dad
helped me out when I needed it you know
you and I become friends and here you
are opening up for them and uh we all
love your music man and just thank you
guys man tell Travis and everybody we
said hey
oh I sure will yeah and uh I got to go
cuz I'm gonna listen a little bit of
Bishop gum while I start this episode
baby all right anything you want is
y'all's tour right now that's the name
of it that's the second song on album I
love it I wonderful I don't feel ever
played that one I don't think you have
man it's a fresh hitter that's dead oh
it's on show at all okay I'll put it out
right here boy we'll start off with some
anything you want with that fresh hitter
right here okay gang baby good man love
you bro I love you alright man I'm proud
of you man be good bye bye
anything you want
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
with another man so soon
[Music]
- a paper Yala team
you got home
[Music]
me you
Wow
[Music]
me you could have anything you want
that's Bishop gun that's burned sharp
and they just I mean they got to open up
for the Rolling Stones and I'll be
honest look you're talking to a guy
right here
I would rather probably you know don't
tell anybody I'd rather hear a little
bit of Goo Goo Dolls and maybe some aa
little Bootsy badass but you know but
just that they got to do it that they
got to live a dream to walk out on a
stage in front of 50 40 70 thousand
people and just that's wild man that's
cool and you can still hear it in his
voice how it pumped up he is you know
and and and just it's so cool man you
know that that so many people that
listen to this podcast and and just how
much a lot of us love their music now
I'm sure there's a lot of people out
there who I put on Bishop of gun man and
they're like [ __ ] he's playing this song
again but but man just cool to be a part
of somebody's dream for a second and
then also the the wild thing for me is
you know and I've talked about this
before that was the drummer burn sharp
from Bishop gun and and and that's the
good man that's the good right there you
know and his dad you know you know gave
me work when I needed it let me work on
their farm let me live with them for a
bit and and he was good to me man and
his father passed away and and his dad
introduced me to the Rolling Stones and
his dad liked to play two instruments
and do two and do our drumming and the
music and and here he is his son getting
to live that dream and live that life
and and just have that experience you
sometimes you know our fathers are our
mothers are somebody before us has to
take they have to kind of take an L or
they have to do a lot of the labor so
that the next generation can live a
dream you see it in a lot of places some
family you know somebody has to come to
a certain you know some families have
come to America and the first generation
they have to you know work 50 60 hours a
week and slave away and but then the
second generation they get to have maybe
a different opportunity or or live a
dream and it's funny to think of all
like that when we when we get to have an
achievement or a dream that if we really
think about our ancestors and stuff like
like we get to do that for a lot of not
just for ourselves but just for the
stacks of history that are in within us
you know for our grandmother our
grandfather for our parent great
grandparent you know any of them who
ever went an extra day at work has said
man I'm gonna do a little extra I'm in
and I'm not gonna give up today I'm
gonna get this done so that my son or my
grandchild could live a dream and it's
pretty it's just interesting because his
father played music and he didn't you
know when he tried and he you know
battle with addiction and he didn't he
didn't figure it out but he loved his
kids and there were instruments around
the house and so his son grew up to be a
drummer and now here he is getting to
open up for his father's favorite band
The Rolling Stones it's just you know
life is doing its thing as well while
we're doing ours so but that was the
good man I wanted to just share that
experience uh you know what I'm so proud
I'm so proud of that kid I'm so proud of
a burn you know and and if you haven't
seen him
I swear to God I get thrown a lot of
shitty music dude there's dudes one guy
sent me a whole album it's just him and
his mother fist fighting over a Silas
Berry State like what the [ __ ] is this I
mean look I liked it a little bit but
you know after the third track you're
like damn y'all need to go to neutral
corners you needn't go to neutral
corners because y'all incoming a real
conclusions about this meet but just
really man it's nice to know that uh
over the weekend maybe you were I didn't
have the greatest weekend or we had this
type of weekend but somebody somewhere
is living out their dream they're living
out a moment that to them is very
amazing and then at the following
weekend it'll be our turn or it'll be
somebody else's turn and and we take
turns I want to thank everybody that
came out of San Francisco we did our
best they had mice in the club and they
had mice and ah if you've been to Cobbs
and if your waiter is really little see
if they got a tail because they got mice
at the club every time I turned around I
was like what is that and I thought it
was the government maybe eavesdropping
with little creatures but these were
natural mics because I lifted a couple
of them up and saw the genitals and the
government if they're making like a
little listening mouse a fake one you
know just a little bitty you know a
little squeak drone then they won't put
the genitals on it but a natural mouse
one of God's Mouse and they got the junk
boy you could see that little header on
it got a little skeet dealer or that
little ah you know that little ivory
maker and you could say okay well this
is a real this is a real mouse that's a
city mouse and they had really they
definitely got mice in the club but
great great people there but we had a
rough experience I'm gonna tell you what
it was you know and what it wasn't and
so that's where we'll get into the bad
the single mom so we like to have single
moms come out and you know and I want to
thank everybody on patreon and just
everybody listens to the podcast you
know and I uh you know and I never when
I was young I always wanted to help my
mother out and I could not you know I
couldn't do it I wasn't I didn't have
the means and so that's why we do the
single mom stuff it's just so we can
climb a little bit back up the ladder of
time and try to help a little bit or do
something you know do something nice
that's what we do it for so we had a
single mom that came out and she really
took advantage of the situation
you know she you know ran up a huge tab
at dinner and mostly on alcohol and then
they came to the club the comedy show
and and they her and her friend they um
you know they bought like they ordered
like a bottle of champagne or something
at the club they left halfway through
the show they told the management that I
was racist and they left and and took
the liquor with him out onto the street
so I just want to investigate what
happened because you know I wasn't there
and that's what I've heard I mean I was
there but I wasn't you know I was on
stage and I wasn't able to meet up with
the mother before the show so we had a
caller that called in and recommended
her son we'll call this cat right now
because honestly at first I was really
mad I'm my god it's [ __ ] out here that
was my first thought honestly it made me
mad you know I just felt like this lady
I took advantage of us so let me give
this fella a call and see what's going
on cuz this is the guy that nominated
her this is Michael that nominated
the single mother just want to know yeah
yeah hello hey Michael yes
hey what up man audio oh what up
wrecking hey gang run and I say it nice
to hear your voice today how are you
doing all right doing all right just
that work on lunch for cello now how's
your day huh
oh you having a little bit of lunch what
do you like to have for lunch I like to
have Jimmy John you like that Jimmy job
I like I want the microwaveable smart
ones
oh you got that little smart Bowl huh oh
yeah chicken and noodles and the cream
yeah I like it man
well uh yeah thanks for letting me chop
into your lunch break real quick yeah we
had you know we tried to do the single
moms night out with the comedy show and
this one was a disaster apparently do
you know anything about it no I mean the
only thing I really heard was that like
you were tired and stuff so like it
didn't necessarily happen the way which
I guess normally happen otherwise I mean
I was you weren't feeling well yeah I
was just under a lot of stress and so I
just needed to try and get some rest in
the afternoon but yeah the mom I guess
they went to the restaurant and they ran
up like a huge tab like you know we give
him like 150 dollars and they spent like
$400 they bought a bunch of alcohol then
the real yeah and then they showed up at
the comedy club and and bought a bottle
of alcohol which none of you could do in
a comedy club and left a rant and then
ran out with it they told the management
that I was racist
and they and they left out of the club
with the liquor and and so yeah they
just ran up like a foreigner dollar tab
at dinner and uh and yeah I don't know
man the ship it made me mad maybe kind
of hurt my feelings a little bit
I just want you know why you nominated
this lady yeah no I mean like again like
I I know I just you didn't tell me
anything about that like I mean like I
thought it was kind of weird that she
didn't like hitting me back opes I was
like oh what's going on with the day
Bologna or anything the next day I
interrupt and then that's my shirt I was
like oh it's going why didn't you know
what we saw at like
like everything was fine I'd know I
didn't hear anything about it okay well
what kind of lady is she
cuz yeah I mean it really kind of uh
well I mean at first I was angry no
definitely but but I just want to know
who she is and why did you think or what
made you think or maybe you don't know
her that well I just wanted to get her
that a read on you but on her no I mean
that's that's exact it was starting the
same like no um like I said like I mean
like I told Nick I mean she's been my
mom's like best friends pretty much I
mean they all see the other doll days
she had she went off has I curl you know
whole life and all that but like she's
marriage that kid seems like she's like
she's a psychologist i person like she
helps easy marries was like the VA she
was wasn't it wasn't mira divorce law
stuff okay but um and and like she like
you know and it seemed like she's like
adopted like her niece because because
the house that the her brother something
was like super weird or creepy so she
adopted him her from him and all like
there's been like lot stuff sigh so you
know where though boy yeah I mean like
she'll be see her house for like a week
okay so you know the lady's not a lady
you do not know that was what I'm saying
oh no no no I feel me I had no idea
about I mean I honestly didn't even
think that you should you take it was
all those things were it's just like you
said no we're gonna be in San Francisco
and I was like oh well I'm in right and
they show she let me stay in her house
like she was out of town doing something
else I say and is she going through a
tough time or something do you know
anything else about her cuz I'm gonna
call her I didn't want to know who she
is before I give a buzz yeah and
apparently she's ducked all of our calls
since then but yeah I mean they're from
everything I learned from the management
of the comedy club to the restaurant
that she was just a nightmare she ran up
a $400 tab at a small restaurant yeah no
that's
she bought a bottle yeah like $260
champagne like you know I'm all about
like it just kind of goes against what
we do so I just wondered you know I was
just trying to see if there was a reason
that this is the lady that you would
submit because then it makes me wonder
well well who would submit somebody like
this who doesn't seem yeah no no no um
no I'll try the caller too but I talked
to it like I said I talked on I've known
her my whole life like it's one of those
where I I like I said I literally like
thought was kind of weird I didn't hear
back from her but maybe she had a good
time cool I figured one of those things
where you know maybe he's you know she's
she's older ladies that's verging on
she's like not older and she Mina's on
the thing sounds face she's older she's
not older what is she no she the season
they're like 40s like I'm in like she's
not old like compared to like you I'm
what like 26 right but uh no no I
literally like I've known this lady my
whole life I learned no ideas shoot I I
mean I thought was weird I legit like
I'm being real with you I thought was
weird I didn't hear correct okay I
appreciate it man look here's the only
thing man um thank you for nominating I
appreciate you trying to make the effort
you know obviously you didn't know that
it was going to be like this we've just
never had this experience at all and uh
I'm not surprising sketchy from her not
surprising that she's single at all but
just don't nominate anybody else okay
you know I know you are it's not your
issue look some of it is I'm not I don't
know how to deal with the yet you know
like this should just kind of made me
mad it made me like think because my
first thoughts are I don't want to do
this anymore
you know like but that doesn't help you
know but yeah she uh yeah I mean she
really she offended people at the comedy
club the manager sent me a letter I mean
if she didn't want to go why she
wouldn't just at least said hey that's
very cool but no thanks
yeah I don't know I mean I just don't
know she sounds I mean I don't know her
and out that does not sound person I
know but of course I'm sure every you
know everybody's different like as far
as like way to act with like people they
know versus how they act out the rest of
the world but thanks nominating a man I
appreciate it I'm gonna jump off the
line but uh I appreciate it man I know
you had best interest and we did as well
but yeah just just don't
let's do not nominate anybody else is
that okay I definitely won't like again
it was one of the things where I was
Crisco I knew somebody in for a night
like I said I stayed at lady's house
like a whole week like Sheila means like
what we was right crazy yeah yeah it was
one of those things where I just i legit
thought that she was the legit person I
I'm when she maybe know I'm gonna give
her a buzz and see what's going on with
her I'm
she's ducked all the calls so at this
point I don't know why you know I just I
can't get a read on her and I don't know
what's going on at home but no I'm like
I'm a huge fan man like this is like I'm
I'm yeah I appreciate it man I
appreciate you you know there's no it
there's no part of it is I'm not I'm
angry a little bit and I'm not handling
it very well you know I've had a
stressful week and just I've just
stressed out and just uh you know we
wanted to do something nice and you know
that and that's why you submitted her
and James she's the only thing I've ever
known her for my entire life being nice
like I literally like had I had a bad
experience they just said she came in
drunk and that she was rude and that she
you know then that she left with a
bottle of alcohol which is they said no
one's ever done that from the club but
anyway man it's not your issue but I did
want to let you know that that she took
a bit of your kindness you know and yeah
and I appreciate you listening and I
appreciate you nominating her and and
I'm sorry if I'm if I'm seeing a little
angst you have just had a tough a little
bit of a tough week but no I don't ever
I'll call now and see what's up
but um all right well I mean hopefully
if you're able to get ahold of her and
release you can at least explain
yourself or maybe you know maybe when
she gets wasted she's a complete [ __ ]
I have no idea yeah but I I do apologize
man I'm really sorry that's okay man I
appreciate you submitting her man I
really do and I appreciate you you know
trying to be a part of just something
cool and and we all you know we did our
best and I know you did too and uh oh
yeah and I love you bro have a good day
all right I love you too man have you
saying I'm so sorry about that all right
all right I'm good
all right let's see if we can call this
lady your call has been forwarded to an
automated voice messaging system
the mailbox is full and cannot accept
any messages at this time
good bye well there you go so that's
that but yeah so it's just kind of a
nightmare
I felt about I kind of took it out on
that dude a little bit man but it's
nobody's fault it's the lady's fault
it's the lady's fault and then I get
upset sometimes I want to blame other
people but it's that lady's fault man
but yeah just put like a damper on the
weekend a little bit you know but
outside of that San Francisco was great
man it was great dude it's so beautiful
there dude it's like the city first of
all you really have to be an outdoors
person to do San Francisco they got
uphill they got downhill
they got uphill er down dude sometimes
you don't even know which way you're
going you're just like [ __ ] somebody
help me
there's people going by Chinese people
on donkeys they got everything they got
you know they got secret passages like
they got Sherpas it's they have some
serious Hills going on in that city you
know there's some serious Hills going on
in that city but it was beautiful I mean
it was just beautiful and yeah and yes
but yet so the single mom thing didn't
make things cool man and just the fact
she told the management that at the club
I'm leaving cuz he's racist she's wasted
you know they bought like it's not and
it's not about the money they spent it's
just that they I don't know I guess I
just felt a little taken advantage of so
um you know I I don't know I guess I'm
just not really processing it that as
well as I would like to you know and my
first thought was like aw [ __ ] it you
know I'm gonna get angry at everybody
you know I'll call Nick I call you know
I'm like trying to fit you know and then
but in the end it's just that lady chose
to not be cool and I don't know what's
going on with there maybe she's having a
shitty week maybe you know I could
definitely see probably while she's
single if this the kind of [ __ ] she does
but you know I don't know maybe she just
got drunk who knows
but that's that man but how about Bishop
gun dude you know how about that how
about that they did it they did it
they're doing it man
they're doing it they're doing it don't
do me
that's that Pittsburgh accent you only
hear that in Pittsburgh ain't random
thing that's very Pittsburgh and
different place have different sounds
you know different places have different
sounds you got to think about that you
know this will sound you might get if
you're like in Norway you know wool a
bulky wool a bulky I don't know what
that means but that's like a Norwegian
type of sound you know weird but they do
well potato that's maybe something from
Idaho or something see that cuz the
person said potato in it but they got a
lot of different sounds out there
and you can hear him in different places
what else we got let's take some calls
that came in you know we had a they had
a young fellow last week he called in
and he knocked a gal up because he was
busting you know he's busting and here's
the thing I you know if you're in a
jacket light inside of another person
you can't be shocked if another person
crawls out of that person nine months
later I mean here's the thing if yous
about to do a jacket Latian and I don't
like to say it that much but I'll say
ejack if he's about to do some EJ your
body gives you a couple warnings first
your body says eh eh eh eh I'm a jack in
about eight seconds so after that it's
you got eight seconds to get out the
building papa
if you milling around loitering
if you weren't loitering inside of
someone else's body and you got the
circle of life lit what about the fire
out of your newts man you're done and
there's nobody to blame your your body
gives you eight full seconds dude eight
seconds you could get I mean it's not an
escape room it's not like there's clues
around you know and you got to find this
and that you got eight seconds to get
out of somebody's body and it's very
easy just get out so I'm fired up today
man that anger that lady got me with
that anger you know just what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] bro honestly and if I had a damn
missile I would just if I had a spare
missile I'd throw it at that [ __ ] man I
really really would and I know that's
not very becoming of me but I'll be dang
bro if I had like a little bitty do two
five somebody was throwing tear gas and
I had a gas mask and one extra I'd put
one on and then I just [ __ ] wouldn't
tell her about the other one you feel me
so that's how I'm feeling right now heat
up dude I had sixty wishes I wouldn't
[ __ ] wish for nothing for that lady
and I guess I should actually let me
think about why I'm actually upset cuz
yeah my first you know I just might I'll
get upset and I just want to lash I
don't want to lash out everybody I want
to be upset at Nick I'm you know why
didn't we screen this person you know
why don't we you know like I want to be
you know I'm upset at myself for being
exhausted why didn't I you know make
sure to go meet them during the day
instead of just try to treat them to
something
so I'm trying to think about what makes
me mad what why I'm really mad at mean
I'm just I'm just mad that somebody I'm
mad that I understand why people at some
point say Oh UK's you can't do anything
nice because somebody [ __ ] it up you
know you can't you know you can't put a
water fountain in the park because you
know sudden you know somebody come along
and put on you know oleander in the
water or put dirty poison in the water
and somebody gets poisoned out and
somebody gets poisoned out you know
that's what so that was the thing I
think it that made me mad and then I
think it made me mad that I you know I
don't have all the time that I want to
have I want you know I wish I you know I
should have gone and met with the woman
in advance so then I could get a feeling
as to what's going on if I'm at dinner
with her then I can see okay well she's
drinking way too much this isn't you
know we shut it down so that's just what
it is Broome but anyway I'm gonna get
off some of the serious stuff but well
am i though because let's uh let's take
some calls though they came here for
will because he decided to loiter around
in a woman's body for that last eight
seconds brother that ride that rodeo
will and some is some suggestions came
in for him first let's listen to exactly
what wills what will called in about and
thank you so much for calling will and
I'm sorry I'm a little keyed up today
but let's uh let's replay what will was
struggling with I'm 22 and I still
pretty lost in life man I got my 19 year
old girlfriend pregnant feeling pretty
down because sometimes I feel like she
might be better off the governor she was
she had so much potential you know like
she's going to a really good school
gonna get into pre-med all that all kind
of got thrown away and I can't imagine
that struggle and actually man I applaud
you for reaching out in and and being
willing to just hear what other people
have to say you know and I don't have no
I don't have no child man
look in my pockets I got nothing in
there no children dude and or at my
house or if there is a child on my house
he's he's hiding I know that cuz
sometimes I hear somebody with something
but I looking it's nothing you know and
it's nothing but um but we had a call
from a friend of mine who also has a
really neat podcast and and this man had
some suggestions for you we'll right
here mr. Jaco willing there he is boy
man he looks tough even when you open up
the UM the video player hey what's up
Theo and what is up will from Martha's
Vineyard and do and crew sent me your
audio your question and I want to give a
little feedback for you first of all you
start off by saying that you are 22
years old and you are you you feel like
you're lost in life and first of all I
want to say that there's a lot of people
that feel like they're lost in life and
there's people that are lost in life at
22 and at 32 and at 42 and at 52 so I
actually look at it as a little bit of a
blessing that this little baby is a
wake-up call for you to recognize that
you're a little bit lost and that you
need some direction at 22 that's that's
it that's actually a positive thing and
I also want to say that I know that you
you probably feel like you're
overwhelmed that you got this baby
coming in but the fact that matter is
when when you're having a kid no matter
who you are you're gonna feel
overwhelmed because for the first time
in your life you're gonna be you're
gonna have something that you're
responsible for that's more important
than you and that's that can be heavy
and it can be kind of overwhelming so
just be ready for that another thing
that you talk about is you're saying
that your your girl that's pregnant is
she had a bunch of potential and now
that's all thrown away man her potential
is not thrown away her potential is not
thrown away will she still
same human being she's just gonna have a
baby and everything that she had
potential to do before she still has
that potential you know she if she wants
to go to med school or whatever you said
that she was wanted to do or going to do
she can still do all that she's gonna
have to make some adaptations she's
gonna have to get some help along the
way she's gonna have to get some help
from you you two are gonna have to work
together as a team to make it happen but
you her potential is still there and if
she's if she's a good person and she has
high potential that doesn't change at
all so don't worry about that just gonna
be some work for you and for her as far
as you saying that you think she might
be better off without you that's just
flat-out not true
that's just not true she's gonna need
you the baby's gonna need you that's
just that's just wrong and you know
you're in a point in your life where you
don't feel like you can make enough
money right man that's a problem man
that's that's gonna be hard and what
you're gonna have to do is you're gonna
have to dig in you're gonna have to dig
in to get a roof over the heads and get
food in their mouths and you know it's
gonna be tough and that's sort of the
way life is man life is hard and you
know it's hard but it's also like it's
good and you know I was in the Navy and
you don't make a ton of money when
you're in the Navy and my wife and I we
had three kids we lived in a little tiny
930 square-foot house two bedroom house
with three kids my wife and I our
bedroom our bed was actually in the
living room / dining room so there was a
there was a dining table and then there
was our bed and then there was a couch
and that's where we lived and when you
open people came over and opened the
door to go into our house on the left
hand side was our bed what was something
like so you know what I was driving a
old beat down Dodge Grand Caravan
minivan and living in this tiny house
with my wife and kids and you know what
doesn't matter it's not it's we we were
we didn't think about it we weren't
running around complaining we were just
half
that we were there and doing what we
were doing so don't worry about that you
know another really positive thing that
you say is you say that your girl is
like an amazing girl and has a great
attitude and she's smiling all the time
that's awesome and what you should try
and do is you should you need to try and
be the same thing for her you know don't
be moping around and and feeling like
you can't get anything done no you need
to you need to step up and take action
and that's probably really the final
thing for me is I have a lot of friends
a lot of veterans I know a lot of
veterans and sometimes when they get out
of the military they struggle and they
get a little bit lost of what they're
doing and I always say it's because one
of the main reasons is because they
don't have a mission anymore because
when you're in the military you have a
mission you got something to do
you've got goals you've got other people
that are on the same mission with you
and it's a it's a really positive thing
and then when guys get out of the
military all of a sudden they don't have
a mission anymore well the way I look at
this for you will is right now you have
a mission and it's crystal clear and
that is your mission is to take care of
these two girls that are counting on you
and that means yeah you're gonna have to
work hard you're gonna be working
overtime and I don't know what your
skill set is you know you might be
working at at at McDonald's you might be
working at Wendy's when I was a kid I
worked at Wendy's day no guess what
that's what you do but I'm gonna
interrupt for one second and it's a
beautiful message can you imagine I
would be so scared to order at Wendy's
did you order a you you order like a
junior bacon cheeseburger and next thing
you know you're like you're on a mission
in Afghanistan like that's how I feel
I'll be so afraid to order from
chocolate and uh at Wendy's long word
did pay bills so I worked at Wendy's and
there's people that work in McDonald's
they work at Wendy's they move up
through the chain they end up making
that their life and they make good money
doing it I don't know if that's what
you're gonna do but I'm saying there's
options and you got to go out there and
you got to make something happen and
you're this little
girl that you've got coming she's she's
counting on you to accomplish this
mission so that's what you got to do
well you got to get out there you got to
get on that mission you got to make
things happen and you got to get after
it so that's all I got
thanks for asking me feel good look good
luck to will and of course Gang Gang
that's all I got y'all have a good one
man you know what a good message man
right there will that's a great
significant great suggestions by Jacko
Gang Gang at you bruh back at you jock
and he has a great podcast called Jocko
podcast and if you struggle you know a
lot of young men these days we struggle
with you have to sometimes you need some
to hear that we need to hear somebody
say look you need to get your [ __ ]
you're gonna have to take action you
have to make a mission for yourself or
there's a mission right in front of you
survival taking care of a new-born
someone you're bringing into the world
and the great thing about Jocko is man
is that man he's a loving guy you know
he loves being a family man he has three
beautiful children he loved being a
family man he loves it man and we're
gonna have him back on the podcast this
fall and I mean you know I needed to
hear that too actually it's funny you
can put all this into your own life well
like even while Jaco is giving up a you
a suggestion it's me too it's like you
know just got to stay on the mission you
know we stay on the mission you know we
stay on the mission we don't let things
get choppy things get this or that you
know we stay on the mission and uh but
yeah if you need that if you need to
hear somebody tell you a message that I
mean this guy's been through it all and
he's big in the biceps and he's and he's
just as big as in the heart and that's a
Navy SEAL right there Jocko willing
from Jocko podcast you can check it out
Thank You Jocko man really really cool
man I feel so lucky to just even you
know be able to reach out to somebody
when I need some guidance you know when
we can't forget to do that you know
sometime I sit around like I think like
you know I could have you know it's like
how do we handle things better if I
don't know what to do I have to ask
somebody who's had the experience now I
don't have to take with the suggestions
they offer but to not ask somebody and
just go blindly into stuff for me man
it's just I just you know just a good
reminder
thank you very much Jocko let's get some
other calls that came in for John for
we'll a couple more suggestions from the
hotline here we go what up ciose aside
from Ponchatoula Louisiana gang game
punch a Tula that's Strawberry Festival
dude nice to go of it a boy I eat all
the strawberries and a lot of people
don't know I didn't have you know when I
was young my mom would get strawberries
and my grandmother would grow
strawberries and every now and then they
wouldn't mail down a couple law pints of
them and they were good and one time I
had blueberries on 4th of July when I
was probably about 13 and I'd never had
them before so I'd never even had
blueberries brown until maybe 14 and
blueberries they really are I mean they
are but they're unique you got to admit
it they're unique when you see him you
think I and eating it and then you have
a couple and then you like to hang boy
next thing you know you buying a pack of
you know next thing you know you you
breaking open a Swisher and putting a
couple of blueberries in there and you
just getting just straight-up balloon
tit breath so I remember I had a bunch
of the 4th of July 9 one and they were
big these things were I mean they would
have been at least a size 36 or 38 pant
waist these blueberries were large
I mean what you know a couple of look
like they hadn't been working and just
been living off the government you know
that kind of thickness to him and and I
had a bunch and then a little bit later
I was out on the deck you know that
night and people started tickling each
other because right before I feel like I
was at the age we were on the board
staying at the beach I wasn't my friend
and right before the age when we started
getting liquor and doing doing dope and
all of that that's really when people
started really tickling each other and
people really right before drugs and
alcohol kind of came out that's really
when people were tickling each other a
lot a lot you walk down the street and
see four or five guys with in hoodies
just tickling the [ __ ] out of some dude
until his wallet fell out of his pocket
people were tickling and the thing about
tickling is at first you get giggled up
and then you get you go past that some
guy Lee Jackie Lacey let me tickle
somebody fifteen minutes but it'll
ejaculate its kratom you know anything
can happen but was I talking about Oh
so everybody tickled me so much out on
the patio I was on the balcony of this
we were understanding at a high-rise
thing at the beach and you know a hotel
room and it was way up and they tickled
me so much dude I was in a bath towel
and uh and the blueberries hit me they'd
never been in my system before and
blueberries really you know your body
don't really your body like some but
your body also make it make your body
feel like like there's a mystery some
like in your stomach or in your butt
it'll make you it kind of makes you feel
like you got Sherlock Holmes in your
stomach and then maybe a little bit of
uh you know some of that encyclopedia
brown and your but you fill me in and so
I did um enough blueberries you know how
do you go to the bathroom
and do it you know do you know do the
old uh you feel me do a little bit of
you know do a little bit of that dark
back work you know and indeed they
tickled me so much and I just my bowels
gave out because I still my bowels were
still developing I was fourteen years
old and you don't get fully developed
you know you don't get fully developed
up in your bows until you probably what
twenty to twenty-four and man I'm just I
still feel bad about it but I just I
mean like talk about this kind of gross
and I'm sorry to even say it but I just
just dude he'd right off that balcony
and just from like fourteen stories up
just and they wouldn't stop tickling me
in the towel would come off me and you
know when everybody was tickling me and
even an old person one of the people
that was tickling me was very old and
there's something about watching
somebody tickle your nude skin with
really old hands that makes you it just
does something to you and I don't even
know what it does but but it definitely
does it so anyway sorry but yeah so I I
mean I was just just doing just spraying
basically duty off the balcony just
flying out of me because blueberries
they get real active they have active
ingredients in them they got that Jamie
Lee Curtis in Umbra that active you and
that activity of my bout my bowels just
get activated boy and I just I was just
like a fire hydrant or just dark work
just flying off the 14th storyline that
deal and it got I mean people were
getting crazy man somebody down below I
think one of the security guards shot a
gun up into it up into the cloud I bet
he just didn't know and I don't blame
him I don't blame him you know if a
bunch of body dark has just fallen out
of the sky and I me I'd fire a couple
rounds into it
praise God brother um and so I think
that that pretty much counts as the ugly
yeah we got we got that's the good the
bad and ugly I mean that's blueberries
bruh Nessa blueberries but yeah thank
you for calling from Ponchatoula ter
home at a strawberry festival the
Louisiana Strawberry Festival and if
you'd like to listen to some zydeco
music and do some dance and her you want
to fall in love with somebody or that
you already love a little bit and they
don't know it you take him there and you
go dance and you get him a snow cone and
you and you guys enjoy each other's
company and it's a good place to fall in
love let's hear more I was in a similar
situation about a young man who is about
to have a baby on August 17th about a
year ago well about ten months ago I had
just quit my job I was having some
financial problems I was looking for
another a better opportunity for work
and I found out that my girlfriend was
was pregnant and it shook me I didn't
know what to do I didn't have a job I
was lost scared I was faced with a
challenge that that I wasn't sure that I
could overcome but like you said to you
you got to get active and that's what I
did man I got I got off my butt and I
got after it man I was doing everything
that I had that I could do to make it
happen to give my my girlfriend and my
child the best life made for me I had a
young boy a baby boy so to the young man
that that is coming close you can do it
man the baby is going to get here it's
gonna change your life
just keep moving be active you have a
purpose now and you can do it man know
you can thank you feel Gang Gang Gang
bro and wow what a well-spoken young man
and I mean you could really feel his
concern and you could really feel his
hope for the
for the other young fella for will and
that's cool wouldn't it man human
connection is just man is powerful and
it powerful man it's powerful you know
uh there's something just so powerful
when somebody cares about somebody else
you know and you know it and that's why
you know that's I think that's the thing
that made me the most upset not to make
this about me now that was a beautiful
message man it's a great suggestion just
the chance that the thing you're most
scared of could change your life for the
better that's fascinating isn't it the
thing you're most scared of you most
scared to go into cave at the end of the
at the end of the town the one that says
keep out
and finally after years you go in there
and nine feet in there there's just bars
of gold do you know you just we don't
know but if you stay active that'd both
of these men said that you notice this
general from Ponchatoula
and Jocko said the same thing you have
to stay active you know yesterday man
honestly brother the the lady you know
wrecking up the single mother thing it
made me mad man it made me mad you know
and then it made me sad it made me angry
at myself made me feel stupid for trying
to be for trying to do something mmm you
know and that's okay that's normal stuff
that's a way I feel about things that's
my process or whatever but you know I
talked to a friend last night and you
know she was saying well you know it's
nobody's fault it's just like you just
have to learn together as a group and
you do it better and different next time
but staying active OMA for a run last
night I went to the gym this morning
even though I didn't want to you know we
stay active and the rewards will come
the rewards will come man and it's gonna
come for you and it's gonna come for
this child you may have to do a little
bit extra work now but this child is
gonna have a I mean what if the baby
you're gonna raise is she might be the
next Lady gaga
you know she might be the next Lady Gaga
she might be the you know the first
female evander holyfield baby you never
know it you never know so but that's a
great suggestion let's let's take one
more call for will that came in here but
right before we get to that I got to let
you know that this episode is brought to
you by skill share and look this could
go out if you have a new baby on the way
you have a dream one day you want to
play with the Rolling Stones
one day you want your kid to be able to
do something an ability that's not even
in your families of lineage yet you can
start the ability now start learning it
now you know if I want a son one day
that's fluent in Spanish I'm gonna have
to be able to speak some around the
house when I meet you know when I have a
son you know so this past weekend is
brought to you by Skillshare Skillshare
an online learning community for
creators with more than 25 thousand
classes and design business and more
you'll discover countless ways to fuel
your curiosity creativity and career
take classes of social media marketing
mobile photography creative writing even
illustration whether you're looking to
discover a new passion start a side
hustle or gain new professional skills
Skillshare is there to keep you learning
thriving and reaching those new goals we
stay active you know we stay active you
want to learn filmmaking try low-budget
filmmaking two years from now you can be
doing pornography or doing making your
own Of Mice and Men at the house the
class is low-budget filmmaking tips and
tricks for an indie look one of skill
shares most popular courses you can join
the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for our listeners get
two months of Skillshare for free that's
right Skillshare is offering this past
weekend listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 25,000 classes
Wow for free Wow to sign up go to
Skillshare dot
come / Theo von they're offering you
something and it sounds good
go to Skillshare dot-com / Theo von to
start your two months now
that's Skillshare calm / Theo von let's
take this this call that came in for
will man it's funny how many people love
you will a lot of calls came in you know
it's funny how many people love somebody
that they don't even know or want to
care in the powerful my name is Sydney
and I'm calling in response to will
Bonin and I want to share my opinion
this is regarding the situation so I
maintain a nearly the age of wills
girlfriend I'm also headed to college
with plans of being pre-med okay so
she's a teen headed to college of plans
a brain being pre-med homeward and first
of all I think that while you may feel
very overwhelmed and be having self
doubt about how good of a father you'll
be I think your presence in your baby's
life and in your girlfriend's life is
far more valuable than any sort of
financial contribution you could be hmm
that's really true you know you're
signing in and remember you're the
daughter ain't gonna remember uh you
know it's funny like I don't think back
and think about my father and think oh
man I wish he had this for me or had
this for me I mean my favorite thing
about my dad I just remember he he put
his arm around my neck a couple times
you know and uh you know or he would
tell me that I'm a survivor you know and
and those are the things that I mean
hell my dad used to take money from me
he used to borrow money from me from up
from my allowance and uh but I didn't
care about any of that you know I just
all you care about as a child you just
you know that you guys are together and
that somebody loves you in that they put
their arm around your neck sometimes
let's all work moving and I know you
seem to be worried
money I understand that's totally
reasonable considering babies are
expensive but I think when that baby's
grown up they're really going to
remember the amount of money or the
material items they have they're going
to remember their memories with you
I myself have grown up with my father
being absent most of my life and through
the substance abuse issues and well I'm
so happy with my life I have to say it's
the one aspect I've just anything to
change and I'm very thankful to have a
beautiful incredible mother but I was a
young girl going into womanhood I think
it would have been so amazing to have a
man provide strength and safety to a
family I'm very thankful to have a
beautiful incredible mother but I was a
young girl going into womanhood I think
it would have been so amazing to have a
man provide strength and safety to a
family gang
that's what it is it's a gang man it's a
gang it's a game so some great
suggestions there we'll thank you young
lady thank you very much yeah she said
you know her mother was very it was
amazing but it would have been nice to
have her father there um you know and
it's the as the and in her life she will
she will try and have something
different for her child
you know whenever she has a child it's
like you know we just have to learn our
generation we learn from what our
experience was and we hopefully try to
make a better experience moving forward
all right we let's get uh let's get
another call that came in right here yo
Sam from the Jersey Shore was so big
Sammy huh big Sammy Sammy oh hey Sam and
as some people they say sometime Uncle
Sam you know this yong-chol Sam wants
you you know who has had their didn't
it's a pedophile sometimes um let's take
a call here we go let's go to your new
episode and you were talking about doing
with it but the restaurant used to work
at oh yeah praise God baby shut up Billy
comforter over there are P men and Bank
we used to uh we used to do them
whippets together and just fill each
other's mouths with handfuls of bread
pudding bro again and I used to work at
Hoffman's ice cream growing up in high
school
iconic Jersey Shore ice cream shop and
we would do all the women you know order
extra cases of whipped cream whip this
went down at the Jersey Shore that's an
ice cream shop but yes just brought back
a lot of memories but a fun times being
stupid kids
scoop and ice cream doing weapons and
yeah men have a good one all right man
that's amazing that someone called and
just left that voicemail about the
whippets man I love that that's what's
great about the hotline leave whatever
you got you have a rough you had a
rememory about it doing a whippets leave
it hey remember I used to do them
Hoskins ice cream shout out to them and
the employees of it air and knew it I
can't imagine doing whippets and also
getting brain freeze from ice cream now
that's some serious seriousness I mean
you got a [ __ ] you might wake up in 1840
bro you might wake up and nah in China
or something you might wake up back in
your mother's womb I mean it do you if
you do whippets and you get a brain
freeze and you're wearing sandals breath
I mean you could end up time-traveling
right there you can end up
time-traveling well uh uh you know
sometimes I know how to end the episode
and sometimes that don't you know but I
feel better than when I started so I'm
glad I came here today and uh you know I
for one I quit thinking about myself you
know I quit thinking about the situation
about the lady with the damn singing I'm
thinking it doesn't really matter I
agree but you know let nobody bust our
fault down [ __ ]
I ain't lettin nobody bust our funk down
these funk down busters and I ain't
doing that so but you gotta be good to
yourselves out there we got it will be
back on you know we're gonna keep it
crews and keep it moving and we're not
gonna let anybody ruin our fun you know
we're not folding just because some 40
year olds something person doesn't want
to start to try and take some
responsibility or awareness for
themselves and also who knows who knows
what happened
maybe that [ __ ] got electrocuted or
something wild who knows you know but I
do know that I think you we all know
when we're taking advantage of somebody
we're taking advantage of situation and
and uh I don't know we'll see but I feel
better I feel better after listening to
thinking about will I feel better I feel
more hopeful about his situation and it
just makes me feel better and and yeah
just even just a little bit of break
from thinking about my own problems and
trying to help be a part of a solution
for somebody else's and I feel better
you know and that's really one of the
gifts of existing is just just learning
that and knowing that when I'm feeling
bad there's a way out of it is if I'm
feeling bad if I start feeling about
somebody else I start helping somebody
else feel good then I'm not even worried
about how I'm feeling anymore and what a
neat gift that is Gang Gang man you guys
be good to yourselves you deserve it and
and what it's going on I'm coming up in
Sacramento Las Vegas we got Oslo Norway
Memphis Atlanta a lot of shows coming up
a lot of these dates are already sold
out that's why I haven't been talking
about him thank you to everyone they
came out in San Francisco that didn't
ruin the weekend because the truth is it
was amazing we have so many wonderful
people come out and couples and diverse
diverse as could be man all type of
people people you know people that can
read people that can't
people with darker skin people with
whiter skin people with no skin one guy
in a little had his buddy in a little
jug of saline solution so anything is
possible you know I'm saying umbrellas
for shell a son we in it we in letting
them rain on our parade you guys be good
to yourselves man people are living
their dreams bro
people are living their dreams man and I
ain't gonna let them I ain't gonna let
them take it away from me bro ain't
gonna let him take that away from you
man let's leave out with a little bit of
Bishop Gunn as requested by them today
man anything you want we make it we make
it happen man we do it for each other
gay
[Music]
[Applause]
to a sense with another man's ocean
Oh
you can do it will we got you daddy
[Music]
me
Wow
reminds me a little bit of widespread
panic
[Music]
my life
with
[Music]
Wow
[Applause]
if you just give me what I need you
could have anything you want and who
knows maybe that's that guy maybe that's
wills little daughter reaching out from
from the not here yet
saying hey daddy if you just give me
anything if you just give me anything on
me if he just give me if you just give
me what I need that you can have
anything you want you know maybe that's
his that's gonna be wills tickets of
freedom to its happiness like that guy
from Ponchatoula said if you just if you
just show up for me that your dreams
will come true a thousandfold now you'll
be opening up for the Rolling Stones now
whether that's what you want to do or
whether you just want to be happy
whatever it is you'll have your you'll
have your version of opening up for the
Rolling Stones man maybe that's his
little daughter saying that if you give
me you just give me what I need you can
have anything you want I don't know I
don't know anything but but I'm just
happy I'm not alone I'm happy I'm part
of this group Gang Gang thank you
everybody that came out in San Francisco
man it was awesome and I'm I'm lucky I'm
a lucky guy because I'm living out some
of my dreams and and we're just gonna
continue to make other good things
happen if you have a single mom you want
to submit for Sacramento
we've got Sacramento coming up and you
can hit the hotline nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three and and
yeah if hopefully if they have you know
younger children or something and and
we'll see if we can do something special
we ain't givin up here hello hey Vanessa
hey Theo what's going on not much where
are you are you hiding I was trying to
find a quiet the last place I was in
actually echoed oh no I appreciate that
you at work yeah I want my lunch
actually okay okay um no I just wanted
to say thank you so much for coming to
the show I thought it was so sweet of
you and uh and I just really appreciate
it you have a good time yes I did I mean
I appreciate you for coming out well
that's nice he to say I um and I know
you have a little do you have a daughter
what do you have a little girl yeah I do
she's um 20 months oh she's like four
months away from being 2o dying so she's
really living it up
yes she is oh that's cute and who
watches her while you're going during
the day um I'm very thankful that my
parents are willing to watch her you
know her dad tries to be there as well
in her life he loves her very much but
um the most stable is my parents well
that's awesome well it's great that she
has family around and people that care
about her so you're a single mom
yes well yeah because we just had like
kind of a crazy instance we're not crazy
we just had we had a single mom that
came out last week and you know she got
real drunk and made like a like a scene
and kind of just yeah it was just a bad
it just wasn't and so I was like you
know we still gonna be tough yeah I know
it can be tough you're right actually
and you know what that's a really good
point so maybe she just had had a crazy
night I don't know but we just had like
a spare we didn't get to give her a gift
that was a thing we like to try and do
something nice and I was like you know I
said Vanessa I said I remember you know
I remember her from San Jose and I
started this weekend and so that's why I
messaged you and asked for your number
because yeah we just had a you know we
wanted to do something nice and so we
just wanted to offer just like a nice
gift to you so that you could do
something fun for your little lady
or you were you and the dyad whatever
you want to do and we love him too and
loves you Theo he third piece the one
that put
to you oh that's cool you're you're a
big you know hope for us and the future
and for our individual minds so I really
appreciate the time you do with those
podcasts these shows and all the all of
your life that you put into it um you
know I'm always one feels talking about
addiction or all the hard stuff I'm
always like oh let's see but vo has to
say I'm a big psychology major and so
being with my baby daddy you know I
really wanted to understand as as much
as I could about him and he's an
aspiring comedian - oh cool
whether we're together or not I would
love to support him ever loved my
daughter to look up to a comedian father
yeah that's reassuring that they would
have a lot of fun together - yeah so
there's there's a lot of potential in
that guy oh well I love that you see
that you know I think yeah I mean I just
I love that you're able to see that and
even look past some of the things that
aren't exactly perfect and that's
something I needed to do like yeah I was
kind of upset at the way that things
went with this lady that came out and
but the truth is I don't know what's
going on in her life I don't know why
but you know but I don't want our
program to be derailed and so instead
yeah we would like to send you yeah I
don't want to like we just want to send
you like a financial gift and you guys
can do something fun and take her and
and dad out or something and uh and I
just wanted to say thank you for your
support and I could even just when I met
you like this past week you know the
second time and you just have such a
beautiful energy about you and you know
your daughter's gonna be very lucky and
so this is actually this will in part
this will be this exactly what I needed
today so thank you oh thank you this is
exactly what I needed to finish off my
birthday weekend oh dang yeah how old
are you boy I'm I'm one year into 30 Oh
yeah not there you that baskin-robbins
girl 31 yeah but I look like I'm 22
oh she looks about 11 when I saw I said
this might be a Kurt there might be a
crime going on this girl looks like
about 11 we'll give a hug your daughter
are you are you guys Latinas or no yes
latina oh my daughter is latina black
and Caucasian dang that's that
neopolitano oh yes is beautiful well I
look forward to meet her one day and
give her dad a hug for me and uh and you
guys have a good day YouTube here thank
you so much I love y'all keep doing you
yes ma'am I will about man
so we win this round boy we didn't give
up we won this round
I remember that young lady Vanessa I
sent her a message she has a little girl
I said hey can you give me your phone
number we called her we got the job done
boy so you know that's the thing you
can't slip too much and you might miss
your gift so if we're gonna do something
really nice for her we're gonna send her
five hundred dollars and uh and it
doesn't matter how much we're sending or
whatever but you know uh but we win this
round boy so we taking Noelle's on this
one son but that's it that's it and
thank you guys for sticking through this
one and you know we learn as we go we
learn as we go
I'm gonna play that Bishop house along
again dude I like that song
that's quite a hold you got Oh me all
right let's do it one more time for
Bishop gun I don't want to thank Michael
for nominating he nominated it uh you
know what lady he tried his best thank
you Michael and I'm sorry if I gave you
a hard time and I want to say thank you
everybody and we don't stop baby you
know not this time we ain't taking this
L bro we might take it the next one son
but we ain't takin this one and if you
take action and you show up you can have
anything you want
and
oh [ __ ]
broke to a favorite auntie
[Music]
yeah take that Satan
you